from time to time we all ask some deep
and difficult questions why is the world
filled with woe how can we make it
better how do we give meaning and
purpose to our lives well as impossible
as these questions may seem there are
some people with confident answers to
them well what about the rest of us many
people know what they don't believe in
but what what do we believe in in
enlightenment now I suggest that there
is an alternative system of beliefs and
values the one that we associate with
the 18th century enlightenment in a
nutshell that we can use knowledge to
enhance human flourishing enlightenment
ideals I suggest revolve around four
themes reason science humanism and
progress let me say a few words about
each it all begins with reason and with
the understanding that traditional
sources of belief are generators of
delusion faith revelation tradition
Authority charisma mysticism intuition
the parsing of sacred texts are all ways
of being wrong reason in contrast is
non-negotiable
as soon as you try to provide reasons
why we should trust anything other than
reason as soon as you insist that you
are right that other people should
believe you that you're not lying or
full of crap you've lost the argument
because you have appealed to reason
human beings on their own are not
particularly reasonable cognitive
scientists have shown that we are liable
to generalize from anecdotes to reason
from stereotypes we seek evidence that
confirms our beliefs and we ignore
evidence that disconfirms them and we're
overconfident about our knowledge our
wisdom and our rectitude but people are
capable of reason if they adopt certain
norms free speech open criticism and
debate logical analysis fact-checking
and empirical testing which brings me to
the second Enlightenment idea
science science is based on the
conviction that the world is
intelligible and that we can understand
it by formulating possible explanations
and testing them against reality science
has shown itself to be our most reliable
means of understanding the world
including ourselves an important
enlightenment theme was that there can
be a science of human nature and that
beliefs about society are testable just
like any other beliefs about the world
the third enlightenment value is
humanism that the ultimate moral purpose
is to reduce the suffering and enhance
the flourishing of human beings and
other sentient creatures humanism is
feasible because people are endowed with
a sense of sympathy an ability to show
concern for the welfare of others
another recurring enlightenment theme
now by default our circle of sympathy is
rather small we tend to feel the pain
only of our genetic relatives our
friends our allies cute little furry
baby animals and that's about it but our
our circle of sympathy can be expanded
through forces of cosmopolitanism the
mixing of ideas and people finally this
leads to the enlightenment ideal of
progress that if we apply knowledge and
sympathy to reduce suffering and enhance
flourishing we can gradually succeed
[Music]